[Musica]
oggi Nascondino di
Halloween dobbiamo trovare tutte le
creature che sono scappate dal loro
mondo di Halloween dobbiamo catturarle
con il mio nuovo libro La città stregata
per farle tornare nella loro dimensione
Ma dobbiamo sbrigarci perché il tempo
sta per scadere esatto Ma quale sarà la
prima creatura scopriamolo subito ma voi
cliccate un mi piace qua sotto Sì
andiamo
[Musica]
Sì il libro ci ha portato fin qua
probabilmente c'è una creatura nascosta
in questa stanza Sì ma dobbiamo stare
attenti Magari
qui
m Fortunatamente non c'era nessuno
Attenzione però sì atteno andiamo di là
[Musica]
vite pozioni velenose forse la creatura
che qua è una strega Sì sì ho capito
però non toccare lascia Magari è
pericoloso toccare queste cose non non
sono cose
nostre Ah qualcosa mi
appunto che cos'è
questo sembra
sangue Ma no non è sangue è solo
inchiostro rosso è inchiostro per
scrivere Non credo che sia inchiostro
questo sì va bene Io vado a cercare di
là dobbiamo
sbrigarci devo cercare qualche
informazione nel libro La città straga A
proposito è appena uscito online in
libreria voi ce l'avete
vediamo ci dovrebbe essere qualcosa qui
No qualche
indizio
Oh due scope Magari sono due streghe m
ottimo indizio questo Ciao sono l'emoji
di Anita A proposito di lupi mannari e
vampiri nel mio nuovo libro La città
stregata c'è una trasformazione il lupo
mannaro è un mistero da risolvere se non
ce l'hai ancora Prendilo subito perché
per i primi a prenderlo ci sarà in
regalo un poster autografato e ricordati
di cliccare mi piace tuttto questo video
Prova a cliccare mi piace entro 3
secondi 3 2 1 tempo
scaduto continuiamo ad indagare qui vedo
anche dei
vampiri questo si fa molto
[Musica]
interessante c'è qualcosa
qui
ma ma qui c'è
qualcuno
che
succede
Aiuto vampiro la creatura L'abbiamo
trovata dobbiamo catturarla presto sì sì
devi andare via vai via con quei brutti
vacci Sì tu bambino devi tornare al tuo
mondo di appartenenza non puoi rimanere
qua nel mondo degli umani Oh Sono così
felice che mi avete trovato sapete oggi
avevo molta sete sete di
sangue
dov'è
andato sono pronta a trasformarmi in
vampiri non pensarci proprio a
trasformarci con il libro ti facciamo
tornare nel tuo mondo di Halloween
adesso no non ho intenzione di tornare
nel mio mondo sapete è molto bello stare
qui a trasformare piccoli asserini in
vampiri come voi e poi di là Conte
Dracula regna e io non lo sopporto più
Conte Dracula conosci anche Conte
Dracula presto Anita fai qualcosa Apri
il libro e catturalitutti.it
[Musica]
ancula ma visto che ha accennato a
Dracula prima perché non mi parla un po'
di di di com'è questo Dracula come si
comporta nella vita di tutti i giorni
Beh sai Conte Dracula è il re dei
vampiri e vorrei che fosse più scarso di
noi quando in realtà è più bravo però lo
odio perché non ci lascia manco una
goccia di sangue non dà il l'opportunità
di mostrarci a noi bambini più giovani
cioè io ho solo 150 anni mentre lui 1800
Ma cosa puoi capire tu stupido
[Musica]
umano adesso che è distratto il momento
giusto per provare col secondo punto
debole
l'aglio
presto No io no Mi toccherà tornare nel
mondo di Halloween da
Dracula Però stavolta proverò a
sconfiggerlo
catturato abbiamo preso la prima
creatura ma ora dobbiamo sbrigarci a
trovare le altre prima che vadano in
giro nel mondo di noi umani sì andiamo a
controllare da quell'altra parte Magari
Ok l'altra creatura dovrebbe essere qua
vediamo
[Musica]
dov'è Non è
qui sembra che non ci sia nessun sono
qua nemmeno nascosto qui in mezzo ai
cuscini è tutto regolare Ehi ma da dove
viene questa
[Musica]
musica volete con me Che cos'è È una
bambola cattiva È il momento di scappare
Non possiamo scappare dobbiamo
catturarla è una bambola cattiva proprio
come qua nel mio libro oh no dobbiamo
Dobbiamo scoprire allora qual è il suo
punto debole per catturarla Sì solo
scoprendo il suo punto debole possiamo
catturarla e farla tornare nel suo mondo
di Halloween pensiamoci pensiamoci
perché non volete giocare con
me per favore giochiamo insieme no no no
no no non vogliamo giocare con No questa
volta passiamo No no perché nessuno
vuole giocare con
me si stato si sta arrabbiando te l'ho
detto che dobbiamo scappare
inquietantissimo
[Musica]
giochiamo vuole spiaccicarella eh quale
potrebbe essere il suo punto debole
Spostati
Spostati perché nessuno vuole giocare
con me Voglio solo schiacciarmi col mio
martello
sono così
sola aiuto Dobbiamo trovare il suo punto
debole per catturarla eh eh aspetta
aspetta Credo di aver capito qual è il
suo punto debole quale il suo punto
debole è la solitudine Sì giusto
possiamo catturarlo Adesso vai Apri il
libro
Wow adesso dovrò tornare a giocare con
le bambole non potero giocare con gli
umani Wow presa abbiamo abamo preso
anche un'altra creatura siamo a buon
punto Questa volta però ciè mancato
veramente un soffio era super vicina lei
ho avuto molto paura S era molto paurosa
ma adesso andiamo a catturare le altre
creature presto andiamo presto andiamo
andiamo Ma è mercoledì Adams quella sì e
lei Forse con lei sarà più facile
convincerla a tornare nel mondo di
Halloween Ottima idea Andiamoci a
parlare Dai
andiamo Siamo siamo qua per riportarti
Nel tuo mondo di Halloween ma io non
voglio ritornare Nel mio mondo io voglio
restare qui e diffondere malinconia e
tristezza malinconia e tristezza tu non
appartieni al mondo degli umani devi
tornare nel tuo di mondo e quindi
dobbiamo catturarti con il libro e
portarti Nel tuo mondo porterò la
malinconia a tutto il mondo a cominciare
da voi Credo di aver capito qual è il
tuo punto debole Tu sì sì certo ho
capito Ah
Lasi terra la devo catturare col libro
Ehi ma non funziona perché non funziona
è certo che non funziona Devi dire la
sua debolezza e la sua debolezza è
l'allegria
Ok allora
allegria
Oh sono riuscito a catturare mercoledì
bravissimo e ora andiamo subito a
prendere l'ultima cre ora là fuori
[Musica]
andiamo il libro dice che la creatura è
qua nelle vicinanze tu vedi qualcosa ho
sentito un abbaio ma forse se è un cane
è un cane non può essere lei la creatura
No un cane non è una creatura scappata
da Halloween a meno che non è un cane
mannaro un
[Musica]
lupo
lo
sapevo aut
scappa Aspetta io so qual è il punto
debole dei lupi mannari qu è il poole
luna
[Musica]
piena fatto abbiamo catturato l'ultima
creatura abbiamo VTO la C sei ancora non
avete il nuovo libro La città stregata
andate subito a prenderlo è ora
disponibile in libreria online cliccate
nel link in descrizione Ciao
ciao